-Performing his number one hit,
"Fancy Like"
from his EP "Country Stuff,"
here's Walker Hayes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh-wee!
Hey!
Gonna go.
Come on, Matty.
Uh.
Ooh, c'mon.
♪ My girl is bangin' ♪
♪ She's so low maintenance ♪
♪ Don't need no champagne
poppin' entertainment ♪
♪ Take her to Wendy's ♪
♪ Can't keep her off me ♪
♪ She wanna dip me like them
fries in her Frosty ♪
♪ But every now and then
when I get paid ♪
♪ I gotta spoil my baby
with an upgrade ♪
-♪ Ayy ♪
-♪ Ayy, ayy, ayy ♪
♪ Yeah, we fancy like
Applebee's on a date night ♪
♪ Got that Bourbon Street steak
with the Oreo shake ♪
♪ Get some whipped cream
on the top too ♪
♪ Two straws, one check, girl,
I got you ♪
♪ Bougie like Natty
in the styrofoam ♪
♪ Squeak-squeakin' in the truck
bed all the way home ♪
♪ Some Alabama-jamma,
she my Dixieland delight ♪
♪ Ayy, that's how we do,
how we do ♪
♪ Fancy like, oh-whoo ♪
♪ Fancy like, oh
let's go ♪
c'mon ♪
♪ Fancy like, oh
hey ♪
♪ Uh, don't need no Tesla
to impress her ♪
♪ My girl is happy
rollin' on a Vespa ♪
♪ Don't need no mansion
to get romancin' ♪
♪ She's super fine, double wide,
slow dancin' ♪
♪ But every now and then
when I get paid ♪
♪ I gotta spoil my baby
with an upgrade ♪
♪ Ayy, ayy, ayy ♪
♪ Yeah, we fancy like
Applebee's on a date night ♪
♪ Got that Bourbon Street steak
with the Oreo shake ♪
♪ Get some whipped cream
on the top too ♪
♪ Two straws, one check, girl,
I got you ♪
♪ Bougie like Natty
in the styrofoam ♪
♪ Squeak-squeakin' in the
truck bed all the way home ♪
♪ Some Alabama-jamma,
she my Dixieland delight ♪
-♪ Ayy ♪
-♪ That's how we do, how we do ♪
♪ Fancy like my new,
clean blue jeans ♪
♪ without the holes in 'em ♪
♪ Country kisses on my lips
without Skoal in 'em ♪
♪ Yeah, she probably
gon' be keeping ♪
♪ some Victoria's Secrets ♪
♪ Maybe a little Maybelline
but she don't need it ♪
♪ In the kitchen light
radio slows down ♪
♪ Boxed wine and her up-do
goes down ♪
♪ Whoo ♪
♪ Ayy
I said we fancy like ♪
♪ Applebee's on a date night ♪
♪ Got that Bourbon Street steak
with the Oreo shake ♪
♪ Get some whipped cream
on the top too ♪
♪ Two straws, one check, girl,
I got you ♪
♪ Bougie like Natty
in the styrofoam ♪
♪ Squeak-squeakin' in the
truck bed all the way home ♪
♪ Some Alabama-jamma,
she my Dixieland delight ♪
♪ Ayy, that's how we do,
how we do ♪
♪ Fancy like ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's go!
Whoo!